moi le maximum que je pourrais payer ses
vingt-cinq mille fois ci on trouve deux
avortements bien tomber avec bien tu
devrais bien couverts 1970 micro
trottoir à paris le sujet le coût des
loyers dans la capitale et les réponses
étaient les mêmes qu'aujourd'hui
prochain les années passent et le
problème reste le même
les loyers sont trop chers alors en 1982
le ministre du logement fait voter une
loi interdisant propriétaires
d'augmenter le loyer entre deux
locations et hausses de loyer abusives
ont trop souvent pénalisés les
locataires qui emménage une
réglementation dans ce domaine se
justifie donc sans aucun doute première
tentative d'encadrement des loyers qui
sera grandement assoupli en décembre
1986 le nouveau ministre redonne le
droit aux propriétaires de fixer
librement leurs prix conséquence
certains loyers s'envolent leur bail se
termine le 31 décembre dernier
ce jour là le propriétaire leur propose
à nouveau le loyer passant de 5900 à
9000 170 francs par mois
certaines associations de locataires
milite pour un encadrement des loyers
par secteur mais il faudra attendre 1989
pour une nouvelle loi est une réforme de
plus pour les loyers les députés
socialistes vont modifier la loi
méhaignerie
parmi les nouveautés un propriétaire ne
pourra augmenter le loyer de son
appartement que si celui ci est
sous-évaluée de prix devrait être
comparable à celui du quartier malgré
cette réforme
la demande est toujours plus forte que
l'offre et les loyers parisiens
continuent de s'envoler
entre 1993 et 2006 les loyers parisiens
ont augmenté de 33 % conséquence
en 2012 ces prix accessibles deviennent
un sujet de campagne présidentielle les
deux candidats nicolas sarkozy et
françois hollande promettent un
encadrement des loyers
la réforme est mise en place en 2015
il est très vite décrié l'encadrement
n'est pas la bonne loi
c'est en fait l'encadrement c'est comme
un thermomètre qu'on casserait pour
arrêter que la température monte
mais la maladie est toujours là le
malade est toujours là il ya toujours ce
manque crucial de logement et c'est ça
le vrai fond du problème aujourd'hui à
paris le loyer moyen pour une surface de
31 mètres carrés et de 1065 euros
[Musique]